québec 29 janvier 2017
19h45 les premiers coups de feu
retentissent à la grande mosquée
alexandre bissonnette un étudiant de 27
ans sans histoire fait feu sur les
fidèles
bilan six morts et huit blessés quatre
ans plus tard on ne sait pas tout sur ce
qui a précisément mené à ce geste d'une
violence inouïe
mais notre enquête nous a permis de
lever le voile sur les réseaux
extrémistes qu'alexandre bissonnette a
fréquenté sur le web quelques heures
avant l'attaqué
sans le savoir il a été en contact avec
de nombreuses publications produites par
un influent néonazis canadien jeff pour
commencer il ya le rapport d' analyse
d'un ordinateur d'alexandre bissonnette
qui a été rendue publique à l'époque
commençons par ce qu'est ce qu'on a
découvert sur les activités de
bissonnette sur internet à ce moment là
on voit qu'il était extrêmement les
attaques passent énormément de temps sur
les réseaux sociaux
il effectue des recherches à propos de
thouars de masse il y avait beaucoup de
nouvelles qui parlait de bons frappé à
l'époque avait
décidé de bannir les ressortissants de
ces pays a gardé beaucoup de la pop
regardée le tweet premier ministre
justin trudeau qui régissait à ceux qui
disent écoutez on veut accueillir toutes
les personnes qui fuient la persécution
parties du monde et il regardait toutes
sortes de visiter des pages de figure
influente dans l'extrême droite mondiale
un peu partie normalement mais un conte
qui me qui a attiré mon attention que
l'ex homme seul est devenue cité la
peine quatre heures avant avant
l'attaqué est un compte twitter que ça
plairait c'est une contraction devrait
violent et réfugiés et c'est un compte
twitter qui diffusait parfois sans
commentaires des articles qui parlait de
juillet d'immigrants qui est un petit
kienan des crimes ou dans des attaques
violentes ont peu partout il semble
comme frappée de voir alex ambitionnait
revisiter sa contre la prévert la taxe
surtout étant donné le contexte de
toutes les autres choses qui qui qui
visitait ce jour le web
ce fils tout était l'associé la surface
mais toi tu es allé au delà de ça tu
t'intéresses et à la personne qui se
trouvait derrière ce fait nous et eux et
c'est là où ça devient de plus en plus
intéressant mais c'est ce dont j'ai
réussi à trouver la personne qui gérait
ce compte twitter c'est un néonazi
canadien quand même ses influences
influents dans ces milieux là donc j'ai
pu le crack et dans 2 forum néo nazi
on peut le voir avoir des conversations
avec d'autres extrémistes comme lui donc
qu'ils sont un peu plus à l'aise d'avoir
des discussions sur ses vraies
intentions
puisqu'on apprend ainsi que ce compte
twitter ou et que geohot ça fait partie
d'une tactique de radicalisation très
très intentionnel de la part des
extrémistes de la personne qu'ils
consultent ne sait pas que c'est un
outil de propagande néo nazis dans
lequel elle pensait avoir consulté les
informations elle même elle voit ces
félons qui lui font peur ou qui la
choque
et puis qu'elles partent à la recherche
de plus d'informations et qu'elle tombe
sur du matériel qui va la pousser encore
plus vers l'extrémisme
donc on le voit la personne qui gérait
ce contenu le dit dans les forums
extrémistes que c'est important de
cacher ses intentions
on dit pas je suis ni en asie
être convaincre de toi aussi néo nazis
il faut commencer par des petites des
petits pots va la radicalisation il dit
il dit lui même et je le cite on
n'essaie pas de les pousser de a à z
on essaie de prendre leurs mains et les
pieds de a dit ensuite de b à c ensuite
2 c à d pour qu'ensuite la personne
façon cheminement vers une
radicalisation plus extrêmes donc avec
son compte twitter que alexandre
sonnette
or consulter le jour de la taxe a
atteint son but donc on sait pas quel
effet ce contrat a eu sur la
radicalisation établi mais il ya quand
même un ca s'inscrit dans un contexte
qu'on regarde quand on regarde
l'activité l'activité sur l'ordinateur
de l'ex le jour de l'attaqué
ça rentre dans un bruit de fond qui
s'envolent pointant une direction puis
une image que cet individu l'a lui même
utilisé pour illustrer ce processus là
c'est tiré d'un film
la matrice avec la pilule bleue et la
pilule rouge tu peux plus comment il est
utilisé mais c'est une expression qui
commune dans les cercles extrémistes
la fameuse pilule rouge c'est le moment
où une personne réalise qu'ils allaient
passer à un autre niveau dans sa
radicalisation qu'elle peut plus revenir
en arrière
6-2 souffrir la matrice où le personnage
central ni au bond doit choisir une des
deux pilules sont rend la pilule bleue
il retourne à sa vie confortable mais la
vraie vérité va être recherché à tout va
bien si prend la pilule rouge mais il va
voir la réalité mais il va devoir passer
de réseaux services battre contre un
ennemi donc ça peut ça la mentalité
derrière ça c'est que quand ces gens-là
avaler la pilule rouge
il peut pas revenir en arrière cependant
le mas qui essayait de faire les
extrémistes avec des choses comme le
compte twitter youtube the world c'est
justement provoqué un moment de paix le
rouge donc de présenter des histoires
tellement sordide que la personne est
tellement choquée qu'elle peut plus
revenir en arrière
dj ben je sais pas jusqu'à quel point
c'est possible de ramener son contexte
actuel ou en tout cas un passé très
récent la chaux contre le capitole on en
a parlé à l'émission avec la mouvance
cannon tout ça dans quelle mesure cette
même dynamique là est en place ici mais
depuis depuis la taxe sur le capital
vont les réseaux sociaux se sont mis
un profil aux ménages ils ont enfin ici
le président option petit mois de
twitter il ya eu un balayage de dizaines
de milliers de comptes qu aux normes et
en réaction à cela il ya bien des
supporteurs de tram qui ont décidé de
quitter or même les réseaux sociaux à
grand déploiement se disant bon c'est de
la censure on veut plus rien savoir
il quittera en faveur de plates formes
qui sont pendants le moins modérée et
est ce qu'on voit ce que les extrémistes
les procédures les groupes les plus déjà
été reprises extrême déjà établis sur le
web et d'autres voient ça comme une
bonne chose
une possibilité de recrutement ils
veulent aller chercher les gens qui sont
mécontents quelques jours après perdu
l'élection qui pensent peut-être que
l'élection était a été carrément truqués
puis ils ont une intention et c'est bien
définie de passe présenté comme étant
des extrémistes de néo-nazis de se
présenter comme également aussi je tends
fans du prisme ventura voici voici des
lectures que je te suggère qu'ils
espèrent ainsi provoquer des processus
de radicalisation chez ces gens là donc
ce qui est arrivé au capitole et la
réaction des réseaux sociaux
la réaction des services policiers aux
états unis il ya bien des extrémistes
qui voient ça comme une bonne chose et
le jeune homme qui gérait le conflit
kurde du world sont le voit dans la
parfaite opportunité pour nous de les
rejoindre plus de gens parce que le bain
il ya un bassin de gens qui sont
vraiment vraiment fâché puis sont des
proies parfaite pour aller les chercher
le chemin vers la radicalisation il
souvent sinueux partout dans le monde
des experts étudient les méthodes
d'endoctrinement sur le web
employé par les groupes extrémistes
processus de radicalisation d'alexandre
bissonnette est semblable à d'autres cas
connus
il suffit d'appuyer subtilement sur les
bons boutons pour enclencher une spirale
de haine venant parfois tragiquement à
des gestes violents
monsieur tanner bonjour et bienvenue
décrypteurs bonjour vous vous attardez
depuis longtemps à toutes ces mouvances
extrait mais c'était quand même j'opère
sur les réseaux sociaux
êtes vous surpris d'apprendre
qu'alexandre bissonnette aurait sans le
savoir est exposé à du contenu généré
par un néonazi influent pays contenu en
fait de la distribution et de la du
volume de ses discours problématique que
l'on peut trouver sur dans l'espace
médiatique sur les plates formes à la
fois facebook twitter youtube mais
également sur des plates formes plutôt
le financiel en fait non je ne suis pas
surpris ai dit qu'est ce qui fait que
ces stratégies ces techniques ou ces
méthodes ont du succès et près de
certaines personnes en particulier
certaines personnes sont peut-être plus
deux vendeuses de ce type de discours de
ce type de discours qui présente dans
une certaine mesure une sorte de
prêt-à-penser à un ensemble de riz de
d'idées reçues en fait qu'ils peuvent
agir comme un réconfort pour des
personnes qui en éprouveraient de l'
angoisse à une difficulté à lire
l'environnement dans lequel elles sont
la traite et monsieur tanner dites nous
quelles stratégies précisément sont
utilisés par ces personnes pour faire
basculer certains internautes du côté de
la radicalisation
généralement les personnes qui sont
influentes sur ses plates formes là
utilisent des stratégies que l'on trouve
également en dehors de tout discours
radical on peut penser par exemple aux
influenceurs sur instagram qu'à partir
du moment où au bout il
tiennent une masse critique si on veut
dire d'abonnés là il peut faire du
placement de produits dans le contexte
en fait des idées radicales
on observe les mêmes pratiques on l'a vu
beaucoup avec des comptes de personnes
qui étaient liés à l'ald wright ou une
fois que ces influenceurs justement ces
personnes ont réussi à galvaniser la
tension finalement d'un nombre
relativement critique et bien
progressivement en fait on va leur
vendre des idées qui sont de plus en
plus problématique en fait et qui dans
une certaine forme se polarise de plus
en plus et si on allait au delà de ces
stratégies qui sont employés et quel est
le rôle des plateformes qui héberge des
contenus comme cela les plateformes au
même titre que des grands des grandes
plateformes de distribution vont de
recommander des produits en fait sur la
base de nos habitudes et de nos achats
en fait c'est plate forme la
problématique qui héberge des discours
fonctionne selon le même principe on a
beaucoup entendu parler par exemple de
chambre des cours de filtres de bulle
sur le mode de la recommandation en fait
ne vont offrir que des contenus qu'ils
ne vont pas remettre en cause
en fait les six des dix personnes moi
dans tout ça ce que je reproche et à
leers et qui est difficile quand même
d'établir un lien entre l'exposition à
ces idées extrêmes là et le fait de
poser un geste violent fin alors de là à
établir un lien de cause à effet je
pense qu'il faut apprendre beaucoup
beaucoup de précautions cela étant ce
que cherche aussi les personnes qui
véhiculent ce discours là c'est si vous
me permettez l'expression de chauffer
les gens à blanc c'est à dire de les
provoquer de les pousser en fait dans
leurs retranchements et dans leur colère
de de faire valoir cette colère de
l'oeuvre de la provoquer en espérant que
justement certains fusible saute en fait
que certaines personnes passent à l'acte
c'est à dire merci beaucoup pour cet
entretien au revoir merci